mullan la nueva película de acción de
disney que protagoniza una guerrera que
se hizo leyenda gracias al largometraje
de animación de 1998 ha despertado
malestar por parte de algunos
espectadores no por su contenido sino
por el lugar en donde se rodó disney
incluye agradecimientos especiales a 8
entidades del gobierno de changjiang una
provincia en donde grupos defensores de
los derechos humanos han denunciado una
fuerte represión contra los musulmanes
uigures entre los abusos expuestos
figuran detenciones masivas
esterilizaciones y trabajos forzados
también se agradece el departamento de
propaganda del partido comunista chino
la película moulin es vista como un
intento de china de mejorar su imagen
mientras varios periodistas y activistas
piden su boicot en 1946 disney publicó
la canción del sur en donde se glorifica
la vida en una plantación en términos
dolorosamente racistas acertadamente
avergonzados disney más tarde retiró la
película ahora es difícil encontrar una
copia se puede decir que emulan es su
película más problemática desde entonces
no por su contenido sino por los
bochornosos compromisos hechos por
disney para
por qué deberíamos boicotear moulin se
trata de hipocresía en las películas de
hollywood aseguran adoptar la justicia
social en realidad se postran ante la
china autocrática vergonzosamente se
avergüenzan ellos mismos defendiendo
valores en los que no cree en las
películas deberían ser algo más que
dinero el presupuesto de 200 millones de
dólares ya se ha inmerso en una polémica
después de que la protagonista del ife y
respaldar a la policía de hong kong en
su represión contra los manifestantes
prodemocracia el año pasado
disney de momento no se ha pronunciado